I have a challenge for you today.
I challenge anyone to tell me what substance
Jared Kushner communicated in the 60 second
video that I'm about to show you.
I already mentioned earlier that Donald Trump's
slumlord son in law, Jared Kushner, son of
convicted felon Charles Kushner, showed up
at the White House coronavirus virus press
briefing last Thursday.
And his presence was not only sinister.
It was also dystopian.
At one point, Jared Kushner went on this rant
about how the stockpile is for us.
It's not for the states or Britain.
At another point, Jared Kushner spoke for
58 seconds in a screed laced with meaningless
management buzz words that I believe is record
setting.
I believe that in the 60 seconds I'm going
to play for you, Jared Kushner has set a record
for the most meaningless buzzwords per minute
without communicating anything of substance
whatsoever.
So let's look at it together.
And what I suggest you do is really focus
and make an effort not to be lulled by the
words that he's saying and realize that he's
speaking a lot, but he's saying zero.
He's not saying anything here.
The question to Jared was about, you know,
data being used to make decisions.
When do you send ventilators and masks and
supplies to states?
Jared has famously said New York is asking
for more ventilators than they really need.
States don't really need all the stuff they're
asking for.
And he's sort of addressing here how decisions
are being made.
I contend Jared says nothing of substance
in his answer.
Take a look here where the president asked,
is that all of the recommendations that we
make be based on data?
He wanted us to be very rigorous to make sure
that we were studying the data, collecting
data.
A lot of things in this country were happening
very quickly.
And we want to make sure that we were trying
to keep updating our models and making sure
that we were making informed decisions and
informed recommendations to him based on the
data that we're able to collect and put together.
The president wants to make sure that we had
the best people doing the best jobs and making
sure that we had the right people focus on
all of the things that needed to happen to
make sure that we can deliver in these unusual
times for the American people.
The president also instructed me to make sure
that I break down every barrier needed to
make sure that the teams can succeed.
This is an effort where the government is
doing things that the government doesn't normally
do, where we're stretching, where we're we're
we're acting very quickly.
And the president wants to make sure that
the White House is fully behind the different
people, running the different lines of effort
to make sure that we get everything done in
a speed that the president demands.
We collect and look at data, we update models,
we make decisions and make recommendations
based on the data.
We get the best people in the right jobs.
We have people focused correctly.
We want to deliver.
Teams must succeed.
We are breaking down barriers.
Donald Trump directed us to act quickly on
this.
Jared Kushner said nothing.
And you know that if Vanke is sitting at home
super impressed with this.
Wow.
Look at that great job that Jared is doing.
Mike Pence was standing nearby looking pleased
with that.
Dumb smirk on his face because it sounded
good, like clearly this guy's more articulate
than Donald Trump and people were probably
refreshed in a way that he wasn't struggling
to get through a sentence like Donald Trump.
But he said nothing.
And this is called management in some circles.
What Jared Kushner said, they're not doing
anything.
I'm not talking about doing anything.
Just saying stuff like that is called effective
management in some circles.
And so this is why we have a real problem.
So my challenge remains.
Tell me what data and actions were actually
communicated there by Jared Kushner.
I'm hoping I'm hoping that we don't see Jared
back at another one of these press conferences
ever again.